julien de côté pour vos trente ans vous
faites un beau cadeau vous commencer le
tournage de votre première série à vous
votre personnage principal est une fille
qui a perdu sa mère qui vit vraiment
symbiose avec son père c'est votre
histoire ou son personnel non ou effet
seuls ses bases et serait sur ma vie un
peu j'ai une relation très spéciale et
crée très unique avec mon père qui est
un personnage en soit le plus grand que
nature qui personne ne peut rester
indifférent
sincèrement papa pour les pour des
bonnes raisons parce que c'est quand
quelqu'un d'incroyable savait qu'une
simple un pilier puis dans ma vie
quelqu'un de très important qui a été
nous a eu très jeune qui a été
endeuillée très jeune donc vécu de longs
en ayant des enfants de jeunes enfants à
charge
à mon âge je l'avais déjà sa famille de
constituer ce duel en arrière de la
cravate dont je peux même pas je
comprends même pas comment il fait pour
être nos simon pas dans les
circonstances mais vraiment c'est ma
muse tu sais un peu j'avais envie de
témoins ce monsieur françois peu drôle
c'est grâce à lui je gèle m qui j'avais
envie de bercy qui me fait tellement
rire à chaque fois que je le vois une
férir pour différentes raisons dont je
me suis un peu à noter ses meilleures
phrases et de leurs aînés l'inspiration
et l'idée puis c'est ce que j'avais
envie d'amener ça à l'écran qui pourra
user les gens meilleurs
c'est à l'âge de 4 ans voyant michelle
pfeiffer dans le retour de batman que
vous avez décidé de devenir comédien
exact comment ça s'est passé
ça a été un coup de foudre je sais pas
comment l'expliquer c'est vraiment une
relation 12h que j'entretiens non ma
tête avec michelle pfeiffer je laime je
la trouvais grandiose forte je sais pas
ce personnage m'a vraiment inspirée peut
pas être fait pas tous les faire un
parallèle avec le décès de ma mère qui
était assez récemment le pire c'est
quand même un modèle sans fard la psycho
pop à deux semaines c'est un modèle
féminin fort qui m'a impressionné c'est
un jeu quelque chose à faire qu'elle
estime depuis vos débuts à l'âge de 11
ans à la télévision et au cinéma vous
avez poche au milieu nos étés à tva
les étoiles filantes à radio-canada en
même temps il y avait ramdam à
télé-québec part comment vit-on son
adolescence son enfance sur des plateaux
tournage tous les mois je l'ait vraiment
bien vécue parce que c'était ça ma
vitesse tout ce dont j'avais envie je
rêvais de faire ce métier depuis
toujours je le faisais en fin de semaine
depuis quatre ans donc j'avais vraiment
du plaisir à le faire de ce crime si d
amitié très forte qui sont toujours
d'actualité c'est souvent dans ce genre
à faire la connaissance de catherine
brunet qui était une amie donc on se
voyait entre les tournages
noémie yelle sarah jeanne labrosse j'ai
beaucoup d'amis que j'ai rencontrés sur
les plateaux puis qu'on promène on
partageait la même réalité je distille
confronter directement
je veux revenir sur les cinq saisons de
la série le chalet dans le chalet il ya
le personnage de lily c'est vous julien
côté s il y avait une grosse différence
entre les deux et c'est son nom m non
c'est sûr qu'elle est on s'est un peu
calqué sur nos personnalités de bans
apprécié après cinq ans on rend
tellement dans la peau du personnage
qu'on y mettait un peu plus de soin puis
moi où je m'étais je ressemble quand
même beaucoup aliliche quelqu'un de très
très protectrice en amitié mais j'ai un
peu de peau c'est celle que j'aime pas
trop quand je me retrouve sur la
rencontre de nouvelles personnes
vraiment plus comme est elle très beau
très protectrice de mon cercle mais
c'est sûr que c'était voilà c'était que
ça servait part par le fait qu'on les
connaissait tellement ses personnages
on traîne pour les olympiques on a
beaucoup par exemple je parle aussi du
film tu dors nicole que j'ai beaucoup
aimé il s'est même rendu à caen - ouais
c'était fantastique ça d'autant plus que
sa marque et ils ont appris en dames
virginie tous ceux où j'ai travaillé
quand même assez intensément g1 estiment
deux périodes un peu plus creuse 1,2 en
août je tombais influent entre deux
castings couleurs de 12 ans jacques
collard d'une femme
donc ça fonctionnait pas bien puis j'ai
eu un peu et j'ai eu plus de temps parce
que parce que c'est ma passion c'est mon
métier
donc me demandais si j'étais un petit
peu en train de me demander s'il fallait
pas une réorientation si ça me voulaient
survivre aussi les principes mais
j'aurais jamais quitté le métier mais
dis moi peut-être même retourner aux
études pour avoir un gant fin du mois
mais finalement ils ont une telle est
arrivé puis ça a été je dirais le plus
bel été de ma vie où j'étais de toutes
les seins mais c'est un personnage
fabuleux avec encore une fois une équipe
incroyable j'ai fait des superbes
rencontres puis à sarp en fait ça
relancer la machine après pour ne plus
jamais arrêter donc ce lanctus et
émotivement c'est si cher à mon coeur
mon projet je pense que vous êtes sur
une belle lancée
merci beaucoup j'ai bien écouté
merci je sois ici quand vous respectez
pas la différence
[Musique]